what lies beyond the Star Wars Galaxy
nobody knows for sure but Ahsoka might
be about to show us ahsoka's fifth
episode is quite the journey and it ends
at the beginning of an even bigger one
after being knocked into the sea by
balin's skull at the end of episode 4
Ahsoka Tano finds herself in a
mysterious Force realm where she comes
face to face with her old Master Anakin
Skywalker as Harris and duller searches
the planet sitos for her Ahsoka revisits
her tragic life story through a series
of Clone Wars flashbacks I'm teaching
you how to lead
how to survive
and to do that you're going to have to
fight
Anakin pushes Ahsoka to a limit in the
world between Wells and even attacks are
outright but it seems that his
aggression is all a kind of game a way
to help his old Padawan find some peace
within herself and sure enough Ahsoka
awakens from the ordeal with a powerful
Aura of Serenity she then quickly
divines a way to pursue Morgan ellsbeth
Sabine Ren and the others even without a
star map this is because cetos is home
to a herd of pergil the hyperspace
traveling space whales that took Ezra
Bridger and Grand Amaral thrawn away in
Star Wars Rebels at the end of Ahsoka
episode 5 Ahsoka uses a force to
convince the perguel through the force
to allow her and who Yang to dug their
ship in its mouth tucked away inside
they set off through hyperspace and we
already have some Clues as to where they
might be going as Ahsoka herself
acknowledges to huyang she has no idea
whether or not the per gear will
actually take them to Sabine Ezra and
thrawn because there are only three
episodes left the writers don't have
much time to play around in other places
but journeying through hyperspace isn't
as simple as hopping from point A to
point B prior to Ahsoka many believe
that thrawn was simply hiding in some
Far corner of the unknown regions an
Uncharted sector of the existing Star
Wars Galaxy notably the ancient Sith
planet of hexagon is located in the
unknown regions along with the remnants
of the Empire that would later become
the final order if a Socrates to travel
through that region of space on the way
to thrawn's Galaxy we could get a
glimpse of what's been going on there
the Mandalorian season 3 already
established at the shadow Council of the
Imperial Remnant is waiting for thrawn's
return hiding in the unknown regions
until someone can bring him back the
unknown regions have barely been
explored in canonical Star Wars stories
which is fitting given that they remain
Uncharted in Universe we know that
thrawn species the chess also hails from
the area and that is quite different
from most known sectors of the Galaxy
but while the unknown regions are
mysterious even less is known about what
lies Beyond them and ahsoka's journey
beyond the confines of the Galaxy opens
up a number of exciting opportunities in
Canon Ahsoka is the first major Star
Wars story to Voyage Beyond Galaxy
however the non-canon Legends timeline
established some details of what lies
beyond the outer rim most famously they
use on vong invaded from a neighboring
galaxy in the eu's New Jedi Order laying
ways to beloved characters and whole
planet the yuzan vong were divisive at
the time because they felt like such an
intense departure from the usual tone
and style of Star Wars but that doesn't
mean we won't see some influence in
whatever Ahsoka finds out there it's
also worth noting that the cannon thrawn
novels feature a similar race to the
yuzan vonk called the grisk they're not
quite as horrifying or dangerous as the
classic Legends villains and they live
in the unknown regions not a separate
Galaxy but there's a definite
possibility that thrawn's presence in
Ahsoka could lead to a new version of
the yuzan vong storyline one that places
a grisk in their stead the implications
that Ahsoka story holds for the greater
Star Wars franchise are even more
fascinating Disney can't stay in the
Skywalker Saga forever eventually news
stories will have to be told and many of
them are likely to be completely
divorced from the existing Star Wars
narrative after all that's how you bring
in new fans and keep the story going for
younger Generations because there's
already so much diversity in the main
Star Wars Galaxy a new one might not
sound like a huge deal but that's a
galaxy with no Jedi with no Sith
Republic or Empire it's a huge pool of
possibilities just waiting to be tapped
you've taken your first step into a
larger world
all in all ahsoka's journey into the
great beyond could be the start of big
new things to Star Wars